Shh time to go hunting
bit early it down right grab a spear
oh it's pointy change your underpants
today changed it with dongle never mind
excellent the edge of stone is a very
long live the edge of bronze I've got to
save the tribe you need my tribe in pain
dare you take him away and kill it
slowly
ah if we win we can have our Valley back
but if we don't beat them we'll spend
the rest of our lives and then working
down in mind
what's your mine pretty brave paper
and stupid
no you stay I don't want to attract
attention
for thousands of years flocks have
migrated smoothly across the skies that
is until he came along I'm giving you
one more chance to grow up so you belong
to this flock lead the junior fliers I
can't fly with the kids they're childish
this is a family friendly communities
you are not family friendly yeah so
what's the problem do we have to migrate
in a v-formation but next spring those
your kids
chert larry has other plans we got it
separated from our flock can you help us
or not I would say aye man or not fine
come on let's go now hey if he doesn't
step up get on your shoulders
not a chance and they don't let off you
have no idea what you're doing do you
they're all what
crazier is your brother indestructible
whatever I say goes
I am NOT a baby for your information I
am 16 days old 16 days Oh what kind of
ring figures
paradise
for over a century the hotel has been
his life but next summer
I got
oh you can eat buffet whoa service pop
yeah so impressive it's like a hotel on
the water
okay thank you
oh no Bobby's gonna puke
Chucky's no pants you must be Peter
that's right Oh generous honest pure
graceful creatures oh you know what that
would never of work no pants you must be
right wait did you try to eat me show me
your teeth do you like a go bug it was
you how are you so good to see you
I don't think of one thing that kicked
off on
hello
just a new neighbor I'll explain it to
him we'll share our land around here
hello I'm Bea these gates are incredibly
sturdy I just need to keep the wildlife
out where they belong right there angels
this is their place okay so he's tricked
up there's only one way out of this he's
got a go you know they set traps in my
bed he's a rabbit he wouldn't hurt
anyone his face was so classic I have a
vermin problem an electric pencil keeper
ma'am no stop
look away we can't give up it's how
always it
you're mine rabbit
my two boys getting along nothing could
make me happier I got into this I'm
gonna fix it you beat up Duke DD
hubba-hubba Romeo and Juliet are moving
to a whole new garden all clear it's not
quite perfect but it's ours think of all
the adventures were gonna have me
oh man Katie that is just are you done
Kakui humans coming hoses everyone they
were supposed to live happily ever after
but when their world is in danger Julia
the gnomes broke up there's only one
known to call
I'm sure luck knows sworn protector of
garden nose you mean except for the one
you literally just broke of the durable
panda we can't let anyone hear this but
they're going to smashes or or an
adventure we have to get across that
River you'll need a ship no [ __ ]
Sherlock
you've got a great unknown our next clue
is in the park get directions quickly
this follow the blue line on the ground
until you find the giant red Suns McEvoy
Emily Blunt - attila tear poor mary j
blige and Johnny Depp with original
music by Elton John and Bernie Taupin
you have to go him to come out let's go
to forward hold hold
forgive me I've never been the back end
of a swirl before
Sherlock knows that's not how a squirrel
six it's behind mankini can you
demonstrate you see yes you're acting
like a rear end the japanese
archipelago'
20 years in the future canine saturation
has reached epidemic proportions an
outbreak of dog flu ripped through the
city of Mecca sake
mayor Kobayashi issues emergency orders
calling for a hasty quarantine trash
island becomes an exiled colony the Isle
of Dogs I don't think I can stomach
anymore of this garbage nobody's giving
up around here and don't you forget it
ever your Rex your king your Duke your
boss I'm chief we're a pack of scary
indestructible alpha dogs Atari
Kobayashi
you heroically hijacked a junior
turboprop XJ 750 and flew it to the
islands because of your dog
darn it I've got a crush on you we get
the idea you were looking for your lost
dog spots
does anybody know sparks if he's alive
may very well be living even at this
moment as a captive prisoner somebody is
up to something will you help him
the little pilot why should I because
he's a 12 year old boy dogs love those
we'll find him wherever he is if he's
alive we'll find your dog it's gonna be
a fight
or somebody spoke his language
Wow to the north a long rickety causeway
over noxious sludge marsh leading to a
radioactive landfill polluted by toxic
chemical garbage that's our destination
great get ready to jump
who have we here
this is Richard you know this bird a
little bird
we must migrate before the winter comes
with big dreams there's just one little
problem you are a sparrow
you cannot migrate and this is my best
friend Oleg in Mayan Africa I'll show
them how it's done
that's a crazy dangerous good let's go
this spring Heelys tree it doesn't
matter what you are what you're capable
of you really love them your storks
mm-hmm then I say we show them who you
really are
Richard the stork
you